was für eine grausame was für eine irre
geschichte der foltermord von paraguay
die opfer deutsche der forscher und
geigenbauer bernard von bredow und seine
erst 14 jahre alte tochter hier sind die
beiden im bild ein älteres foto von den
beiden das verbrechen das spielte sich
hier genau ab in deren haus dort wurden
die beiden bestialisch ermordet es ist
das schreckliche ende eines auswanderer
traums wird diese beiden inzwischen sind
die ermittler ein bisschen weiter da in
paraguay es gibt mordverdächtige
ebenfalls deutsche drei männer sie sind
irgendwie bekannte auch der familie von
bredow diese drei sie also sind es die
von bredow und seine tochter brutal
gefoltert ermordet haben sollen aber
warum möglicherweise um den code zu
bekommen für einen tresor mit viel geld
und um unschätzbar teure
musikinstrumente zu erbeuten hier sehen
wir bilder nochmal von den
polizeimaßnahmen dort in paraguay es
gibt wahnsinnig viele fragen einfach in
diesem fall nach wie vor und deshalb ist
unser kollege philipp lichterbeck
dorthin gereist an den tatort und an den
knast wo im moment die drei
mordverdächtigen deutschen sitzen und
hat einfach mit ihnen gesprochen dort im
knast philipp kunz einmal wie es aktuell
der stand der ermittlung was wird den
drei deutschen überhaupt konkret
vorgeworfen warum sollen sie es gewesen
sein
ja ich sage erst mal wo ich hier bin ich
stehe vor einem untersuchungsgericht die
drei sind gerade hierher gebracht worden
werden jetzt einzeln einem haftrichter
vorgeführt sie sind hinter mir in zellen
untergebracht und werden jetzt jeder
einzelne hochgebracht
der haftrichter entscheidet dann ob die
drei weiter in der untersuchungshaft
bleiben oder ob sie eventuell sogar
freigelassen werden die
staatsanwaltschaft wirft den drei ein
komplott vor das ist eine ziemliche
räuberpistole muss man sagen dabei geht
es um geigen er hat von bredow das opfer
soll zwei geigen 2018 ein freund
gegeben haben damit er auf sie aufpasst
lernt er selbst reist
in dieser zeit hat das haus feuer
gefangen und die geigen sind offenbar
verbrannt
die staatsanwaltschaft sagt jetzt dass
das nicht stimmt sondern dass die drei
diese geigen versteckt hätten und jetzt
sie verkaufen wollten und dazu brauchen
sie echtheitszertifikat er sollte dem
stradivarius handeln was meine
erkenntnis noch quatsch ist dazu
brauchen sie im aber das
echtheitszertifikat und an diese um an
diese zertifikate zu gelangen hätten sie
bredow und seine tochter im gefoltert
und umgebracht
die polizei hat dann steigen gefunden
bei einem dieser deutschen und behauptet
jetzt eben das seien die geigen die
damals nicht papst sein sondern von den
drei versteckt worden sein das ist also
eine ziemliche
räuberpistole es ist eine theorie es
gibt dafür bisher keinerlei beweise
was haben die die verdächtigen denn bei
deinem gesprächen gefängnis gesagt
ja die wahl zwischen gefasst erschrocken
verunsichert ängstlich die sagen alle
drei dass sie damit nichts zu tun haben
sie waren auch gar nicht über die
vorwürfe informiert sie sehen als ich
ihnen davon berichtete was die
staatsanwaltschaft vorwirft fielen sie
aus allen wolken
und man muss einfach dazu sagen ist es
gibt keine smoking gun es gibt keine
tatwaffe es gibt keine blutspuren die
staatsanwaltschaft dass diese theorie
aufgestellt und jetzt diese drei männer
ins gefängnis gesteckt und man muss auch
dazu sagen die presse hier ist
sensationell ist ich muss man sagen und
hat auch die drei männer schon
vorverurteilt und ja sie sind
einer von denen sagt er hat große angst
roller kein geld hat und man braucht
einen paradoxen gefängnis geld um
einigermaßen über die runden zu kommen
ein dritter bei dem die galgen im haus
verbrannt sein sollen hat große angst
vor dem gefängnis weil dazu muss man
wissen er ist transsexuell erwarten wir
eine frau und er hat eben große furcht
davor dass er im gefängnis als er drückt
es aus dass ich lebend aufgefressen
werde von anderen häftlingen
zwei dieser männer sind im keller des
polizeipräsidiums untergebracht es gibt
kein tageslicht in dritten hat man
weiter oben eingesperrt
bist du gerade gesagt aufgefressen
werden in dem krankenhaus in dem in dem
wir in der haftanstalt
ja er hat offenbar angst vor
sexualisierter gewalt
südamerika paraguayischer gefängnisse
sind es nicht vergleich noch mit
deutschen gefängnissen du hast einen der
verdächtigen er auch zuvor tagelang
begleitet also vor ort über diesen
schrecklichen fall recherchiert hast was
für einen eindruck hat er auf dich
gemacht wärst du ihn da erlebt
also ich traue ihm das nicht zu aber das
spielt ja auch keine rolle die fakten
sollten lauter sprechen als irgendwelche
eindrücke
der fakt oder fakten sind dass er es war
der die presse informiert hat weil der
druck auf die ermittlung ausüben wollte
er hat dann ein kopfgeld ausgesetzt
zugibt dass zur ergreifung der täter
führen sollte er war erkennt der tomb
raider oder kannte den von verdi seit 20
jahren war sein bester freund hat den
viel geholfen bernhard von redos
überhaupt erst wegen ihm nach paraguay
gekommen und ganz entscheidend für mich
ist das eher ein alibi hat erwartet so
tat macht offenbar gar nicht in arica
sondern aber auf einer seine hacienda
das im norden von paraguay dafür gibt es
offenbar zeugen und außerdem hat er an
einer mautstation auch bezahlt hat sogar
noch das mit tickets er sagt auch bei
ihm wurden die geigen dann gefunden das
ist ja jetzt sozusagen die was die
staatsanwaltschaft benutzt um ihn des
mordes anzuklagen bei ihm wurden geigen
gefunden er sagt er wurde von der
familie prius beauftragt diese geigen
aus dem haus nach dem mord in sicherheit
zu bringen ich habe das haus ja selbst
gesehen wo der mord stattfand das stand
praktisch offen da konnte jeder rein und
weiß diebstähle begehen und bildung
dieser beschuldigte deutsche wollte eben
im auftrag der familie diese instrumente
die sehr wertvoll sind vier geigen in
sicherheit bringen sax gerade diese
geschichte macht auch eine riesenwelle
dort in paraguay wie erlebst du aktuell
die öffentlichkeit und vor allen dingen
aber auch die justizbehörden dort also
wie sehr können wir vertrauen schenken
dass dieser fall tatsächlich gelöst wird
ja die die presse schlachtet diesem fall
natürlich aus und vorverurteilt die
deutschen da wird nicht viel nachgefragt
ich habe den eindruck dass hier ja
schuldige produziert werden sollen das
sagt mir auch der anwalt eines der
männer es wird wenig auf fakten es wird
wenig auf beweise geschaut
die staatsanwaltschaft hat keine waffe
sie hat keine blutspuren keine
dna-spuren sie hat einfach nur diese
theorie und großes vertrauen in diese
form der justiz habe ich zumindest nicht
es kam hier sogar eben meine frau die
sagt ich sei selbst
ein opfer ein justizopfer und sagte die
fahrgeräusche justiz extrem korrupt auf
die polizei und wir sollten da weiter
kämpfen
ja also ich habe da kein großes
vertrauen in das hier gerechtigkeit
geschieht aber wie gesagt die drei
werden jetzt erstmal dem haftrichter
vorgeführt und dann sehen wir weiter